hasta ahora hemos aprendido cómo modelar
curvas en dos dimensiones es momento de
regresar al problema importante que
queremos abordar cómo modelar la parte
divertida los personajes usando
superficies en tres dimensiones y ahí es
donde la subdivisión realmente destaca
las mismas ideas de dividir y promediar
también se aplican en tres dimensiones y
eso significa que la subdivisión también
se aplica por ejemplo supongamos que
empiezo con un cubo puede observar el
cubo desde diferentes ángulos dando clic
en el fondo y arrastrando aquí el paso
de división es un poco más complicado
que en las curvas además de agregar
nuevos puntos medios en los bordes como
este también necesito agregar puntos
medios en las caras como este los puntos
medios de las caras son calculados al
promediar todas las coordenadas de los
puntos de control que rodean esa cara
por ejemplo este punto medio
como el promedio de estos cuatro puntos
y este es el promedio de estos cuatro
puntos el paso de promediar también es
un poco más complicado que en el caso de
las curvas cada punto es re posicionado
nuevamente usando el promedio pero ahora
no es un promedio directo necesitamos
usar el promedio ponderado de todos los
puntos que se encuentran próximos al que
queremos reposicionar hablaremos más
sobre promedios ponderados en la
siguiente lección y justo como en las
curvas podemos combinar división y
promedio en la operación de subdivisión
y si la sub dividimos suficientes veces
la forma obtiene una superficie suave
ahora intentemos esto en la forma de una
dona al subdividir una vez obtengo esto
subdividiendo de nuevo me da esto
en la práctica sub dividimos tantas
veces como necesitemos para crear una
imagen suave la subdivisión se usó por
primera vez para crear un personaje
llamado jerry el del cortometraje el
juego de jerry aquí tenemos la mano de
jerry antes de la subdivisión y aquí
está después de la subdivisión desde el
juego de jerry hemos usado subdivisión
para crear prácticamente todos nuestros
personajes incluso hemos usado
subdivisión para otras cosas además de
personajes como los edificios en los
increíbles porque las superficies
subdivididas son más fáciles para que
los artistas las utilicen a continuación
tenemos un programa en 3d simplificado
para que juegues vamos a jugar intenta
cualquier cosa y todo lo que se te
ocurra no se puede romper y siempre
puedes volver a empezar una vez que te
sientas cómodo con el comportamiento de
la subdivisión avanza e intentaremos el
ejercicio final
después de eso puedes revisar la
siguiente lección que profundiza más en
las matemáticas de la subdivisión haz
algo grandioso